SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
My name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software
engineer at Google
and I'm here at
KubeCon Greg Castle.
Greg is the tech lead of
the security team at GKE.
Greg, you have a huge mandate.
Can you talk a little bit
about what you work on?
GREG CASTLE: Yeah.
So my team handles the
security of a bunch
of parts of the GKE system.
We look after security
of masters and kind
of security
configurations of masters
as well as helping out
with other teams that look
after various other subsystems.
So we interact with
storage, we interact
with the node team,
networking, a bunch of others,
and kind of help drive
security direction
across the whole product.
As well as in the
open source, we
have a number of
people on SIG-AUTH.
So we have a couple of the
leaders in that community,
and we have people on the
Kubernetes product security
team that get all the incoming
security vulnerabilities
for Kubernetes, and triage
them, and respond to them,
so yeah, a lot of
stuff internally
in protecting GKE clusters,
and also externally protecting
Kubernetes clusters in general.
SAAD ALI: That is a lot
of stuff that you work on.
Let's focus in a little bit on
the open source side of things.
Where are things as
they stand today,
and where they
going in the future?
GREG CASTLE: So I think
we've made a lot of progress
recently with--
some interesting areas that
have seen a fair bit of focus
in 2018 have been
service accounts.
So Mike Danese and I are
talking about this on Thursday.
You can come to the Container
Identity Working Group
deep dive, where we're going
to talk a fair bit about how
we had these older service
accounts that Kubernetes first
started with that had a
number of security problems
that were--
have been addressing in 2018 and
moving to kind of a new model.
And the differences
are mainly that those--
that first generation
of service accounts
were basically static keys
that lived in the the secrets
database.
They lived forever.
It was very difficult
to rotate them,
so we've had some security
incidents where a key--
with various, like subsystems
of Kubernetes, where
a key was leaked in some way.
And then we need to move onto a
new Kubernetes service account
and revoke those
old credentials,
and it's all very painful
in the current version
of service accounts.
And so we've developed a bunch
of APIs and some new ways
to mount in these new
Kubernetes service account
secrets that no longer involve
that centralized database.
They can be like kind of scoped
and sort of bound to a Pod.
So a lot of things get easier.
So they're limited
lifetime, the kubelet
will handle rotation of
them automatically for you.
The client-go Kubernetes
libraries have been updated
so that the users--
the consumers of
those service account
tokens don't have to
worry too much about it as
long as they're using
a client library.
And they can be audience-bound,
which is a new thing too.
So previously, there wasn't
any audience binding,
which meant those tokens
weren't particularly
useful outside of--
or they weren't safely
useful outside of the cluster.
And now we can say--
you can go to the
Kubernetes master
and say, give me a
credential that I
want to go use with
HashiCorp Vault,
or I want to go authenticate
some other system.
And you can say, this
token should only
be used with that
destination system.
And that destination
system wouldn't then
be able to turn around and
take it back to the API server
and have some control
over the API server
that that service account has.
So there's quite a bit of--
there's been a lot of work
in that in 2018.
And Mike, in particular--
Mike Danese hae-- led a lot
of that in the community.
And so we're just now
getting to a point--
so some of those
APIs are in beta.
One of them is in alpha in 1.13,
but we're getting to a point
where we need people
to start using them
and get feedback on them.
So if that's
interesting, I definitely
look at the Container Identity
Working Group deep dive
session.
I will talk about that
in some more detail.
SAAD ALI: That sounds like
a lot of awesome work going
on the open source
side of things.
So I think folks are going
to be looking forward
to seeing service account
rotations becoming something
that they can start using.
Can you talk a little
bit more about what's
going on the GKE side
of things in terms
of keeping customers secure?
GREG CASTLE: Yeah.
So that service account work is
playing into a larger identity
effort at Google.
So we are-- we know there's
some kind of usability
pain and some security things
that we'd like to address
with accessing Google services.
So getting access to
Google credentials
to access Google services
is currently more painful
than it should be.
And so this work we're
doing in the community
is kind of foundational
for that work
to improve that identity
integration with Google.
And so there's active
work in that area.
We're not quite ready
to announce it yet,
but if you are a GKE customer,
definitely talk to us about it,
and we can get you involved
early in that process.
And so we'll be improving
the security of the identity
integration with Google, and the
usability of it as well, too.
And I think that's going to be
quite powerful and flexible.
So that's been a big
focus for our team.
There's some other efforts on
the way under like a general,
I'd say, hardening bucket.
So we're both in Kubernetes
and on the Google side.
So on the Kubernetes side,
we've added the ability
for the kubelet to be
bootstrapped from what's
called a trusted
platform module, which
is a kind of trusted,
cryptographic device that
can be used as a root
of trust for things.
And so we want to be able to
have a strong cryptographic way
to bootstrap nodes that's better
than like some sort of shared
key that we give
to nodes to say,
this is a thing that should
be able to join the cluster.
Ideally, we have something
like a TPM that can say,
here's a cryptographic
assertion that says who I am.
And then write rules
about who should
be able to join the cluster.
And so we've added that
functionality into Kubernetes,
and we're working on kind of
interesting Google side stuff
for that too.
So no announcements there
yet either, but there's
more interesting stuff coming.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
So it sounds like a lot
of new, cool functionality
to make Kubernetes
more secure on GKE.
Can you talk more about
the bug bounty program,
and what we do to
discover vulnerabilities,
and how we deal with them?
GREG CASTLE: Yeah, so on
a few different fronts,
Google has its own bug
bounty program right now.
So you can-- if you find a
security vulnerability in GKE
or in, really, any Google
product within the scope
of the bug bounty and GKE is
in scope for the bug bounty,
then we will pay you money.
So please try out, test the
bounds of the GKE security.
And we're happy to
receive those and we're
happy to pay for
those vulnerabilities.
Similarly, the CNCF is also
standing up its own bug bounty
program, and that's
currently in process now.
So we're working on setting
up the structure for that
to be able to handle those
vulnerabilities coming
in from a program like that.
And that will also set
Kubernetes up in a good place
too.
And we're also looking at some--
for Kubernetes and
the CNCF is also
kind of looking at some threat
modeling and that kind of work
too.
So yeah, the bug bounty
program, I think,
is a symbol of an organization
being mature enough
to know that security
bugs do happen.
And if we can force multiply by
taking advantage of that great
security researcher
community and paying for them
for their effort-- it is a
lot of effort to find security
vulnerabilities in
a lot of cases--
then I think it's a real symbol
of maturity and something
that we'd love to see replicated
as widely as possible.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
And I understand we
work very closely
with partners to make sure that
our entire ecosystem is safe.
Can you introduce Shopify?
GREG CASTLE: Yeah.
So Shane, do you
want to come over?
How do you-- join
us on camera here.
So Shane and I are
presenting on Thursday.
We're actually in
the very last--
come in a little bit.
We're in the very last
time slot on Thursday,
so please stick around for us.
But we're talking about a--
kind of in that same vein
of bug bounty programs,
we're talking about
a security issue that
was reported to the
Shopify bug bounty program
that I think is a really
interesting example
that, for the community in
general, we can learn from.
When companies share
these kind of experiences,
I think it's very
valuable to be able to dig
into the details of them,
be fairly open about them,
and talk about how
the attack worked,
how the vulnerability
was discovered,
how it played out, what
the possible defenses are,
and learn from it
as a community.
So Shane, maybe you can tell us
a little bit about the Shopify
bug bounty program and
how that got started?
SHANE LAWRENCE: Sure, Greg.
So I'm Shane from
Shopify, and the mission
of the security
team at Shopify is
to make commerce more
secure for everyone.
And to that end, we have a
comprehensive security posture,
but we know that there are
always going to be bugs.
So our bug bounty
program allows hundreds
of researchers to participate,
attempt to hack our platform,
and if they're able to
find vulnerabilities,
then there's a financial
incentive for them
to disclose those responsibly.
Once they make that
responsible disclosure,
we will patch it as soon
as we find out about it
and correct the problem.
And as soon as we know
that we're secure again,
we release that out to
the public, and that way
other companies can take
advantage of this information.
And through
collaboration, we can all
make the platforms more secure.
GREG CASTLE: Great.
Saad, did you want to jump
back in, or how do you--
yeah.
SAAD ALI: So do you
have any recommendations
for other customers who are
working with Kubernetes or GKE
and what they can do to
improve their security
on their systems?
SHANE LAWRENCE: Absolutely.
So one of the ways that
we've been able to do this
is by working really
closely with our partners.
So whenever we find
a vulnerability
or we suspect there
may be an opportunity
for a vulnerability, then we
discuss it with our partners
at Google, and we
get a good handle
on what the risk of
attack is and what would
happen if it were compromised.
And if it seems like there's
a high severity there,
we might be able to mitigate
it on our own platform,
but that doesn't
help anyone else.
So we can release that
information or we can
incorporate it
into tools we have,
for instance, an open
source tool called
kubeaudit that anyone can use.
And patches are very welcome.
And in that way, we're able to
improve the security posture.
Other people can share
their knowledge with us,
we can share our
knowledge with them.
And in addition
to that, we found
that one of the biggest
things that prevents people
from taking part in bug bounty
programs is low bounties.
So if you're not financially
compensated for your work,
then researchers will
move on to someone else.
So Shopify is very proud that
we offer above average bug
bounties.
We offer substantial
financial compensation.
And in that way, when
researchers find problems
with our platform, they're
encouraged to report it,
and they're encouraged
to keep coming back.
And it really shows that we
value their time and the effort
that they've put into it.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, I think that
goes a long way to helping
secure the entire ecosystem.
So thank you for that.
If we could switch
gears a little bit,
let's talk about KubeCon.
This is not your first KubeCon?
SHANE LAWRENCE: No, actually
this is the second time
that I've been at KubeCon.
I was able to attend
last year in Austin.
It was my first time.
I'd been using Kubernetes for
about a month at the time,
so I was pretty new.
But I'm really excited
to be back here today.
SAAD ALI: Are there any
security related talks
that you're excited about?
Of course, yours
coming up tomorrow.
Maybe you want to
tell folks about that?
SHANE LAWRENCE: Sure.
So there was a
specific incident that
happened about six months
ago where one of our security
researchers found a
vulnerability in our platform,
and it combined a
couple of things
that may have seemed like they
were low risk on their own,
but combined, they could
have led to complete
control of a cluster.
And so we paid our maximum
bounty of $25,000 for that,
and we're really proud
of the work that we did.
We received the report,
and within an hour
and four minutes, we were able
to mitigate that vulnerability.
And I think that some of the
work that we've done there
will be really valuable
to others who are trying
to secure their own platforms.
So I'm going to be sharing
that alongside my co-presenter,
Greg.
And I'm really excited.
I think that some of the
details will be valuable.
I also really enjoyed seeing
Maya Kaczorowski's talk
yesterday on
security, and I think
that was an incredible talk.
I thought one of the
most important things
that she covered there
was the fact that there
are all of these
container escapes
that everyone's
really excited about.
They're really glamorous
or sophisticated,
and almost no one's
using those in the wild.
So I was really happy to
hear her talk about that.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
So if folks are interested,
please check out these talks.
And thank you so
much for your time.
SHANE LAWRENCE: Thank you.
SAAD ALI: Have a great
rest of your KubeCon.
SHANE LAWRENCE: You too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]